[Musique]
ces gouvernements n'ont pas pris la
mesure de l'explosion des agressions il
y a eu du laxisme de la part de monsieur
macron qui n'a pas pris la mesure de
l'explosion de violence et aujourd'hui
il suffit d'écouter le garde des sceaux
qui qui qui nous parle de sentiment
d'insécurité on a envie de lui dire mais
monsieur le ministre
aller sur le terrain rendez vous compte
de ce qui se passe la violence explose
et voilà on s'enferme dans le discours
il n'y a pas d'acte constater c'est
facile agir c'est plus compliqué l'effet
que les républicains ont fait des
propositions extrêmement précises sur
lesquelles la majorité et le
gouvernement n'a jamais voulu s'exprimer
messieurs mc ren est tellement mal à
l'aise avec ce sujet de l'insécurité il
est dans même dans le déni qu'il utilise
en effet le mot incivilités qui ne
correspond en rien à la situation
véritablement à cette dérive violente de
la société française depuis trois ans et
il y ait un véritable laxisme il faut le
dire c'est l'angle mort de ce
gouvernement
notre police est exténué n'en peut plus
elle n'en peut plus des ordres et des
contre ordres de ce débat quitte
incompréhensible sur les violences
policières
bien sûr personne ne tolère une violence
policière enfin c'est pas le sujet le
ministre de la justice nous parle depuis
des semaines du sentiment d'insécurité
est ce que ces policiers qui ont sauvé
leur vie à la dernière minute éprouve un
sentiment d'insécurité est ce qu'ils ont
ressenti un sentiment de mortier sur
leur commissariat
non notre pays est en train de se de se
déliter face à la montée de la violence
et on a un gouvernement qui continue a
commenté projet de loi on l'a pas vu
encore puisque je vous rappelle que le
président de la république nous a
annoncé qu'il serait présenté au mois de
décembre ce qui veut dire très
concrètement que compte tenu des
navettes parlementaires ce projet de loi
ne sera jamais mis en application avant
la fin du quinquennat
pas un mot sur l'immigration pas un mode
d'application sur la loi sur le voile
le président de la république n'en parle
pas les mineurs isolés ils n'en parlent
pas la fermeture des lieux de des lieux
de culte salafistes
il n'en parle pas donc quand même
écouter
soit on le fait sérieusement et à ce
moment là on pourrait d'abord le faire
beaucoup plus tôt parce que là nous
indiquer ces propositions nous encore
une fois est au vert parlementaire les
décrets d'application elle ne sera
jamais mis en application
mais quand vous voulez régler un
problème que vous ne parvenez pas à
identifier c'est impossible et c'est le
drame de cette politique d' emmanuel
macron quand même quand on nous dit
attendait les résultats attendait les
résultats
ça fait trois ans le problème n'est pas
l'islam qui est une qui est une fois
mais l'islamisme qui est une idéologie
qui encourage une société parallèle une
économie paraissait des commerces
présents révèle des écoles parallèle est
un site 8 ensemble qu'on à devoir
d'union de la nation mais d'union très
concrètes pour lutter contre ce fléau de
la soumission à un islam politique qui
voudrait nous conquérir
on nous a dit tout et n'importe quoi sur
le masque tout et n'importe quoi sur les
tests on nous dit tout et n'importe quoi
sur les lits de réanimation écouter
philippe juvin et tant d'autres médecins
en france on a cinq mille lits de
réanimation le même chiffre
le printemps est enfin qui reconnut
quand même bon vingt-cinq mille lits en
allemagne mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait
pendant six mois les français aimeraient
pour vous bien sûr qu'on est tous prêts
à respecter un certain nombre de gestes
et de critères très bien mais le rôle du
politique
en six mois c'est de dire on va doubler
le nombre de lits de réanimation pour
apporter une solution concrète à nos
compatriotes
c'est ça la police je suis inquiet parce
qu'en fait voyez vous il faut comprendre
une chose très simple c'est que tous les
efforts qu'on demande aux français
eh bien ils sont d'autant plus
importants que l'hôpital n'arrive pas à
soigner les gens et je pense qu'il faut
se poser une question
la seule on ne peut pas simplement
demander aux français de porter le poids
de notre absence de réflexion
stratégique c'est ça le sujet on a eu
trop d'injonction contradictoires trop
d'incohérences qui fait qu'à la fin des
faits en crée de la confusion et donc on
crée un mouvement d'anxiété chez les
français et c'est ça qu'il faut corriger
aujourd'hui il faut que le gouvernement
retrouve sa crédibilité on a dit qu en
français ce qu'il veut faire
on y voit plus rien on n'y comprend plus
rien
[Musique]